let's just bring you some breaking news  now and detectives investigating the  death of the  police community support officer julia  james have  charged callum wheeler aged 21  from aylsham in kent with her murder  julia who is 53 was found next to occult  wood in snowdown  just before 4 p.m on tuesday the 27th of  april  officers from the canton essex serious  crime directorate they say  arrested the 21 year old on friday the  7th of may  obviously mr wheeler remains in custody  and is due to appear  via video link we're told at medway  magistrates court  tomorrow and certainly searches have  been taking place in elsham  for three days now lots of officers at  the scene  so the breaking news there that a man  who had been uh  apprehended by police has now been  charged uh  when investigating the death of julia  james has now been charged 21-year-old  callum wheeler